irgendwie scheinen sex und liebe nur
sehr ungenügend wissenschaftlich
untersucht zu sein
trotzdem gibt es einige sehr spannende
erkenntnisse aus der psychologie
soziologie und biologie die fünf
erstaunlichsten enthülle ich in den
nächsten minuten bei pixum zahlen von
fiction
rot ist die farbe der liebe und das ist
jetzt auch wissenschaftlich bewiesen
andrew elliot und daniela nester haben
erforscht wie sich farben psychologisch
auswirken
die ergebnisse waren verblüffend
eindeutig jungen männern wurde ein
schwarz-weiß-foto mit einer frau
allerdings vor einem farbigen
hintergrund gezeigt die frau wurde dabei
vor einem roten hintergrund als deutlich
attraktiver beurteilt in einem anderen
experiment haben sie ein und dieselbe
frau mit verschiedenen oberteilen
abgebildet war die frau in rot gekleidet
fanden die jungen männer sie
attraktiver fühlten sich von ihm
sexuell angezogen und wollten ein date
mit ihr das dann auch möglichst im bett
enden sollte in anderen studien wurde
festgestellt dass frauen in rot beim
online-dating bevorzugt werden und das
tramperin in roth öfter mitgenommen
werden
das geht allerdings nur für jüngere
frauen forscher führen das auf
biologische ursachen zurück die unser
verhalten beeinflussen
jüngere frauen erröten er wenn sie
fruchtbar sind das heißt ein mann
hätte dann die chance nachwuchs zu
zeugen die farbe rot sollen also dazu
stimulieren sich zu vermehren
bei älteren frauen spielt das keine
rolle mehr so dass die farbe rot also
nicht ihre attraktivität steigert wenn
es um sex geht verhalten sich frauen
anders als männer und das ist
wissenschaftlich erwiesen schon in den
siebziger jahren untersuchte russell
klagt wie sich die bereitschaft zu
spontanem sex zwischen männern und
frauen unterscheidet bei seiner
untersuchung wurden männer und frauen
nach einem ersten date gefragt ob sie
mit ihrer verabredung ins bett wollen 70
prozent der männer waren dazu bereit
achtung jetzt kommt 0 prozent der frauen
keine wollte mit dem man ins bett
jahrzehnte später hatte sich die lage
für die männer etwas gebessert
immerhin 18 prozent der frauen würden
mit ihrem date ins bett gehen bei den
männern man es immer noch 70 prozent
der e.coli hat in dieser studie dann
auch herausgefunden woran es liegt und
das sind wieder biologische gründe
während männer meistens einen orgasmus
bekommen ist es bei frauen ganz und gar
nicht der fall
sie gehen vermehrt davon aus dass sie
keine spaß haben werden und legen
deshalb ein spontanes abend
ja meistens ab was folgern wir daraus
wenn es 40 prozent der frauen waren und
heute 18
die zu spontanen sex bereit sind die
männer sind offensichtlich besser im
bett geworden
aber wann halten frauen männer für gut
im bett und leider liebe männer gibt es
dazwischen attraktivität und
performance im bett es gibt wirklich
männer die das so nennen einen
biologischen zusammenhang attraktive
männer haben nämlich einen höheren
testosteronspiegel
sie haben also mehr von dem hormon im
körper das für das männliche und
somit für frauen attraktiver aussehen
verantwortlich ist und diese männer
sind auch besser im bett
david plaz befragte um das
herauszufinden 110 paare und glich deren
antworten mit dem aussehen der partner
ab und es ist laut dieser studie
tatsächlich so maskulin aussehende
männer können frauen öfter zum
orgasmus bringen
und wenn diese männer dann noch sex mit
vielen frauen haben dann leben sie auch
noch gesund wort ja wissenschaftler der
universität in montreal und des
instituts am ohr frappe haben für eine
studie über prostatakrebs die
gesundheitsdaten von 3200 und acht
männern ausgewertet
das verblüffende ergebnis männer die
mit mehr als 20 frauen im bett waren
hatten deutlich weniger prostata krebs
also bei männern die im
untersuchungszeitraum der studio von
vier jahren mit mehr als 20 frauen sex
hatten
da entwickelte sich 28 prozent weniger
oft ein karzinom an der prostata grund
scheinen die häufigeren samenergüsse
zu sein vermuten die forscher allerdings
wird die studie im moment heiß
diskutiert so ganz eindeutig scheint das
nicht zu sein
sex mit vielen partnern und partnerinnen
kann auch gesundheitsschädlich sein
die zahl der sexuell übertragbaren
krankheiten steigt nämlich seit dem
jahr 2000 kontinuierlich an
die hiv neuinfektionen pro jahr haben
sich seitdem zum beispiel verdoppelt und
warum ist das so
kondome werden immer noch zu wenig
benutzt oder stop eigentlich ist es
anders wenn nämlich die letzte studie
der bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche
aufklärung zur jugendsexualität
ansieht dann lägen die probleme ganz
woanders
28 prozent haben schwierigkeiten beim
überrollen 14 prozent der jungs geben
immerhin zu dass ihr penis beim
überrollen schlapp macht bei 22 ist das
kondom geplatzt bei 21 zu klein und so
weiter wer hat denn dann eigentlich kein
problem ein kondom frage ich mich da da
kommt er die aktion von manhart racing
motto user kommt vom verein jugend gegen
aids richtig hashtag von 100 base die
wollen nämlich dass möglichst viele
leute mal ganz unverkrampft mit kondomen
umgehen also die nächste drogerie kauf
kondome und macht was lustiges
verrücktes oder sonstwas damit und
dreht am besten darüber ein video und
mit den kondomen die dann noch übrig
sind übt den umgang
denn wenn es drauf ankommt sollte das
was die bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung aus gefunden
hat nämlich reißen abrutschen schlapp
machen oder sonst was nicht passieren
übrigens ganz viele wissenschaftliche
studien zum thema sex und liebe gibt es
in diesem buch her sehr lustig und
interessant kann ich nur empfehlen suche
kochenden button ja und mehr zum thema
sex gibt es übrigens in diesem video
machen pornos dumm dafür eben hier
klicken allerdings auch in der video
beschreibung wie auch der mehr
wissenschafts news täglich im block und
der app hier klicken
und was meint ihr sind kondome zu
schwierig zu handhaben oder stellen sie
machen sich manche einfach nur zu blöd
dazu an schreibt es um diskutiert es mit
mir in den kommentaren
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran